le congrès hlm justement monsieur qui
laisse a annoncé cette nouvelle se
tenait à montpellier là il a inauguré un
bâtiment appelé antigone référence à la
grèce antique de sophocle qu'a voulu son
concepteur l'architecte catalan ricardo
bofill
si les logements ils sont plus chers à
la construction + 10 % pour les
locataires ils sont au même prix qu'un
autre logement hlm
mais la construction de beauf il
provoque à montpellier de vives
polémiques j'en paye eu qu'une tour
balle le polygone ce quartier voulue par
l'ex municipalité d'opposition se heurte
désormais à un voisin fort différent
antigone architecte en chef du quartier
l'espagnol ricardo bofill
c'est lui aussi qui a conçu cette
première tranche de 300 logements des
hlm sur les visites sans logement du
quartier la moitié souvent des hlm le
reste de l'accession la place centrale
est conçue sur le plan d'une église
italiennes du 16ème siècle
tout cet immense forum les garages la
frapper parce qu'on n'est pas habitué à
montpellier devoir chercher un monument
évidemment avec avec les les bâtiments
qu'il ya à côté ça ça ça ressort
énormément beau fils à loger les
escaliers dans ces immenses colonnes
autres trompe l'oeil les six étages se
cache derrière trois niveaux de fenêtres
quant aux matériaux c'est du béton
teinté qui imite la pierre un pastiche
accuse certains que cette façade
néoclassique en tout cas pas française
je sais que toute la france est un lieu
de rencontre et d'écouté des violences
il ya une culture que je défends c'est
la mienne c'est la culture latine mais y
trône elle toujours le toujours fait
d'une plage du club en france d'une
place la française cette forme d'une
oeuvre d'une immense coupole il va
sortir cette coupole
il est découpé et l'avenue people à ce
moment là c'est les ciels communiste
dans un pays où le ciel est bleu et la
nuit des étoiles
cette cooper coupé à la manière de
borjomi
il va montrer tous les étoiles les
familles c'est aussi l'image du sud
quand vous êtes à l'extérieur vous avez
un plateau vers les émoluments sont
rentrés dans une oasis un autre lieu en
effet ce palente univers et la dea dans
les palmiers fin du quartier dans quatre
ans avec les autres bâtiments confiés à
des architectes locaux
on aménagera un parc de 6 hectares
jusqu'à la rivière du lez
avec guinguette un quartier populaire
dont cohabiteront 7000 personnes à 500
mètres du centre télé l'urbanisme
d'antigone ce choix est celui de ces
deux hommes georges frêche le maire et
l'architecte ricardo bofill
deux hommes dont les villes montpellier
barcelone d'ailleurs sont jumelées était
ce une raison pour faire d'antigone un
anti polygone non ça n'a rien à voir si
vous voulez être secondaire
antigone c'est d'une certaine façon la
tradition grecque et romaine de
montpellier c'est le défi d'antigone aux
lois de la cité salir aux lois d'une
certaine cité qui est dur pour les plus
démunis nous avons voulu j'aurais dit
antigone ça correspond au souci de faire
du logement qui soit beau à proximité du
centre des villes et qui puisse être
habité par tout le monde
c'est une erreur d'architecturé parce
que les réalisations de s'inscrire dans
le temps et dans l'espace
or l'espace autour de nous demandent que
cette réalisation jure au milieu des
réalisations anciennes et dans le temps
on crée me rappelle les architectures
des années 1930 architecture
mussolinienne alors fausse querelle que
celle du polygone et d'antigone qui peut
dire ce qui est beau comme de savoir si
antigone est hors de son temps où le
quartier rêvé par les habitants des hlm
d'aujourd'hui
mais d'avoir juxtaposés de style aussi
contradictoires cela l'histoire risque
bien de ne pas nous le pardonner je vous
parlais tout à l'heure d'un